That distracts the learner from
the main goal, which is to get
lots of exposure to the language.
Steve Kaufmann here and today
I want to talk about grammar,
how important is grammar?
And I'm going to talk about grammar in
the context of all of the details of
languages that we learned in school.
How effective is it to teach these
details if the ultimate goal is
to become fluent in a language?
Now, remember if you enjoy
these videos, please subscribe.
You can click on the
bell for notifications.
By the way, you'll notice that
I have my LingQ t-shirt on.
I just happened to find that in the closet
when I was getting dressed this morning.
Um, at any rate, so, you know, details,
one of the things that struck me in
Manfred Spitzer's book, and I often refer
to it, is the, when he explains that the
brain, our brains and all the brains,
the process of learning is the same.
There are no people with brains that
learn better this way or that way,
our brains learn the same, the same
way we have our likes and dislikes.
But the process of learning is the
same and the brains are better...
our brains are better at forming
patterns, recognizing patterns and
not so good at retaining detail.
So that, uh, the details that we
learn that we keep somewhere in our
short-term memory, we lose them.
But over time, the brain starts
to recognize that pattern.
And that's very much
in my view, the process
by which we learn languages.
So, you know, if you sort of
spell out like grammar, grammar
basically describes usage.
So since languages evolve over time,
sounds in languages evolve over time, uh,
you know, usage patterns evolve over time.
So the grammar which describes
the usage will evolve over time.
So how useful is it to attempt to teach
people how the language, what the rules
of usage are before the learner has had
enough experience with the language?
I think it's not that useful.
And, at least in our school system
in Canada, where they teach French,
they teach grammar, they teach
grammar because it's something they
can easily test the learners on.
And some learners got eight out
of 10 and some got six out of 10.
So learner A with eight out of 10 is
better than learner B with six out of 10,
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
at the end of the day learner A is going
to be better at speaking than learner B.
It may mean that, but it's not obvious.
And there are many cases where learner
B who may be exposed more to the
language, maybe had comes from a, you
know, a country where the language
is spoken hears the language at home,
but he speaks it incorrectly from a
grammatical point of view and so he does
poorly on the test, but he understands
and he communicates, and there are
many things, examples like that.
So my feeling on grammar and other
details of the language is that
they can be introduced at any time.
They should be introduced when
the learner is interested in them.
It's, it's true that many of the patterns
in the language, you know, are not
noticed when we hear even hearing the
language over and over again, we don't
notice certain niceties of pronunciation.
We don't notice that certain
syllables aren't stressed.
We don't notice, you know, the,
whatever it might be, third person
singular in English, uh, of the
present tense, uh, it takes an "s".
Whereas the other forms of the verb don't.
We don't notice these things.
So sometimes it can be useful
to point these things out.
Therefore, I think it's useful to have
a reference grammar [book] and every
language that I have learned, I have
tried to get a hold of a grammar [book]
as small as possible with no exercises,
no drills, just what happens in the
language and a bunch of examples.
And so I look at that
and I see the examples.
And it's just helping my brain get
used to how the language works.
The patterns in the language and
this approach, I think is the same
for other details of the language.
For example, pronunciation upfront,
when it is explained to you
using international phonetic, the
international phonetic alphabet that
this sound is pronounced this way.
I don't personally find that very useful,
uh, I find that with the availability of
audio today, text to speech, I can hear
how it's pronounced, but it is possible
that three months later having listened
to the language many, many times, I
still don't notice that a certain vowel
is pronounced a certain way, or I don't
notice that the stress is a certain
way, uh, or in the case of pitch accent
that it's this way rather than that way.
And so at that time later on to help
us notice things that might've passed
us by it's useful to refer to these
explanations, but there's far too
much emphasis placed, placed on these,
these explanations or these details
of a language, uh, with the intention
of testing people on these details.
And the result is normally not very
good because it distracts the learner
from the main goal, which is to get
lots of exposure to the language,
lots of listening, lots of reading.
And as Krashen says, in an environment
that is low stress, that is enjoyable.
And if you do that, and if you
trust your brain, a lot of these
things will be acquired naturally.
And therefore you needn't be tested on if
the goal is comprehension, they don't even
need to test you on your comprehension.
Even if you misunderstand something,
the fact that you are putting in
the time, listening and reading
will eventually enable your brain
to get used to the language.
So, yeah.
In my approach to language learning, I
want to sort of, deemphasize the sort
of details, the grammar, the other
specific explanations, because our brains
are not as good at dealing with these
explanations and rather encourage people
to find ways to enjoy the language.
Listen to the language.
Don't worry about what
you don't understand.
Don't worry about the
mistakes that you make.
If you continue to expose yourself to the
language, you will gradually get better.
And when you are interested in, genuinely
curious about specific details, you can
look them up and it's never been easier
to look them up, but, but don't get
yourself a thick grammar book like this.
Get yourself a thin as possible
grammar book, which explains what's
happening in the language with
examples, without exercises, without
drills and go over it regularly.
Don't try and block learn the
conjugation table of a specific verb.
Just look it over, forget it, look
it over and recognize you're going
to forget it and go back there.
And eventually over time that activity
looking things up, grammar rules,
whatever, uh, which are limited
unlike the amount of words we have to
learn, which is almost unlimited, the
grammar rules are actually quite nice.
And if you keep on flipping through a
sort of a thin grammar book, you will
eventually get a very good overview
of what happens in the language.
And when you combine that with lots
of listening and reading, you're
going to get better and better at
the language rather than trying to
fight the rules of grammar upfront.
So that's my take on grammar and I I've
covered this subject before and I'll leave
a few other videos on the same subject.
Bye for now.